foreign
[Music]
thank you so much for joining my talk
um as a brief introduction uh I am a
co-founder and director of scientific
Affairs within Western uh so first I
wanted to really thank the organizers
for putting together this meeting and
I'm really excited to have the
opportunity to share with you what we're
doing here at Western
so for today's talk I hope to First give
you a sense of why spatial genomics is
such a powerful technique and then I'm
going to walk you through the technical
aspects of our platform technology and
how it differs from some other spatial
Technologies
and finally I've also used a couple of
showcase examples to illustrate how you
can apply this Technologies to address
different biological questions
some of you may know special genomics is
actually quickly becoming a essential
tool for biological research and we're
truly excited to see what new biological
insights and discoveries it will enable
and the impact it will bring in the near
future
so just to keep um everyone uh some
context first we know that a logical
tissue are quite complex and are made of
many different cell types that Express
genes very differently
understanding that gene expression
profile within each cell and across the
tissue is quite critical for a better
understanding of the Ian Sava logical
system
as human or over the past two or three
decades we haven't seen a revolution in
genomics research which really enables
us to characterize the biological system
and unprecedented scale and resolution
as you can see from this Slide the
landscape of genomic Evolution from bulk
RNA sequencing to single cell sequencing
we can now suddenly interrogate the gene
expression profile of individual cells
and really use this information to
understand the cell composition as well
as cell cell interaction
however sequencing based Technologies
actually do have a fundamental
limitations because they don't really
provide any special concepts of what
you're looking at to do the sequencing
cells either have to be destroyed or
disassociated and thus we lose the rich
spatial information for the
interestingly organized 3D biological
tissue
and as you now can appreciate many
biological problems do require
multiplexed spatially resolved and
single cell measurement we really see a
huge demand for technologies that can
satisfy this criteria and that's what
western is really working on WE aim to
bring the best especially resolved
single cell genomics tool to the
research community and for clinical
research in the future as well
so our platform technology licensed from
Harvard University is called Murphy's
which stands for multiplexed Aero robust
fluorescence in situ hybridization this
is the RNA Imaging based technique that
can locate and quantify different RNA
species at the same time with
substantial resolution
some of you may know that they are
actually existing RNA Imaging
Technologies such as single molecule
fish
however the limitation of these
traditional Technologies is that the
gene stupid is relatively known
oftentimes you can not provide more than
five Gene species at the same time
multiplexing is very challenging for
these traditional methods because it
relies on the use of sexually distinct
florals to report different RNA species
and since we don't have hundreds of
thousands of different guys available
then it's very difficult to do hundreds
thousands color images
but in contrast Murphy's really enables
highly multiplexed RNA Imaging capable
of resolving hundreds to tens of
thousands different RNA species within
cells
so as you can see here there are three
key aspects that really make this highly
multiplexed measurement possible which
is complementary labeling sequential
Imaging and aerial robust barcoding
to perform more fish as you see on this
side we use the combinatory labeling
strategy to label different RNA species
with a type of oligo probes that
contains different barcodes
then each Buckle is going to be detected
through fluorescence Imaging by a
sequential round of Imaging and the
fluorescence on and off pattern
generates a optic barcode and we use
this to help resolve different RNA
species
this specially resolved RNA profiling
data really gives the physical picture
for the cell or tissue of Interest shown
by the image on the right with now
colored dots indicating different RNA
species and granite indicating different
cell boundary
The Murphys was initially invented by
our scientific co-founder Dr xiaoi Drum
at Harvard University in 2015 and since
the initial publication in the Journal
of science it has been validated by a
long list of Publications other from
Charlotte's lab or from the other labs
and has already brought many
transformative discoveries and actually
specially resolved transcriptomics with
selected as a method of the year in 2020
by natural methods and Murphy's was
featured though it really highlights the
excitement it has already generated so
far
so furthermore around the world there
are already many institutions who are
already adopting Murphy's other
independency or through participation of
Western's Early Access program this
includes 10 more institutions not even
listed on this slide
So within wisdom we're actually making
Murphy's more broadly available to our
commercial platform solution called
murscope in early March we announced the
commercial launch of our Moscow platform
this platform facilitates this whole
Murphy's measurement with a complete
reagent instrument and software solution
it combines uh the advantages of
Murphy's technology with the streamlined
workflow as shown here from the
chemistry reagent site gym panel design
to Downstream instrument hardware and
software and using this we maintain the
sensitivity a higher multiplexing
capability as well as high resolution is
established by Murphy's and this really
makes the whole system easy to use
so here is a summary of merch
Technologies key features
looking on the right first Murphys has
high multiplexing power through academic
Publications Murphy's actually has been
demonstrated up to 10 000 genes but in
our first generation of reagent offering
we measured hundreds to thousands of
genes simultaneously in single sample
secondly Murphy's has exception of
spatial resolution we can localize RNA
transcripts with subcellular resolution
this really annoys us to zoom in into
individual cells and directly analyze
the spatial distribution of the intar
transcriptome or you can even zoom out
and start to analyze the molecular and
cellular profile of the entire tissue
and biologically meaningful nanoscales
as well
thirdly Murphy's has high sensitivity
since Murphy's is based on single
molecule fish which is often considered
as the gold standard for quantifying RNA
copy numbers in cells so Murphy's also
maintains that single molecule
sensitivity
and for people who work in the Single
Cell field they can probably start to
appreciate why sensitivity and detection
efficiency matters because many lowly
expressed genes don't often have too
many counts in this measurement and
Murphy's High detection efficiency
really enables us to detect those slowly
expressed but functionally important
genes very easily
and furthermore Murphy has very high
cell throughput we can profile Square
centimeter type to tissue with hundreds
of thousands of cells in a single
experiment no follow-up sequencing is
needed you get all the information in a
single experiment run with no additional
sequencing cost
and finally Murphy's is very flexible
and we can perform Murphy's on almost
any tissue or sample types
so as a gene version profiling tool as
you can imagine Murphy's at its basic
phone report the location and quantities
of RNA species as well as the cell
boundary information
but with so much information it really
opens up many application areas for
example we can use this tool to profile
the gene expression profile in situ map
and catalog cell types and state in
tissue and map the interstellar
organization of the transcriptome
furthermore you can even use this tool
to do image and based genetic screens
such as crispr screens or apply it to
image DNA and Trace chromatin structure
so in the next few slides I'm going to
walk you through a couple of showcase
examples to really illustrate how we can
use Murphy's to gather biological
insights
so the first showcase illustrates how
Murphy's could be used to profile gene
expression profile in situ across very
large tissues as we know to understand
tissue function it is critical to
understand how different genes are
expressed at different anatomic sites
and how the gene expression profile
change during this onset progression and
after drug treatment
so in this showcase example we used
murphage to profile around 500 genes to
map out the major cell types and cell
receptors in the mouse brain the gene
panel as Illustrated here include around
50 canonical macro genes and around 433
cell receptors including gpcrs and rtks
on the slide what you're seeing in the
lab in this uh nine by seven millimeter
image what you're seeing is the
distribution pattern for a subset of
eight genes out of this 483 Gene panel
hopefully by glancing at the picture I
hope you can already see the very
intricately layered structure in the
mouse frame uh for example across this
corner section you can even zoom in to
each single field of view as shown in
the image in the middle now to get a
high resolution view of the gene
expression profile for individual cells
so all 483 genes are uploaded in this
image you can really start to
interrogate the gene expression within
individual cells
or somebody Plus on the right this
measurement is highly quantitative and
reproducible for example by looking at
the correlation plot with bulk r96 data
here we got correlation coefficient of
around 0.88 and in between biological
replicates we go to a correlation
coefficient of 0.99
and what's really important to notice
that Murphy's can very accurately
profile genes with a very dynamic range
of expression profile including genes
expressed at less than one copy per cell
as you are seeing in the correlation
plot with bulk RNA sequence in doubt the
expression range for those profile genes
stands four orders of magnitude and many
genes with fpkm be 0.1 or even 0.01 can
be very accurately measured
so this High detection efficiency of
Murphy's really started to allow us to
characterize slowly expressed but
functionally important genes just to
highlight how this actually manifest in
real data how we can look at a quick
comparison between Murphy's measurement
and measurement coming from an oligar
array that capture-based technology
so here we're considering matched brain
samples between these two technologies
uh you're seeing about the images on the
left half of the brain flies a show over
the and we're comparing the counts of
transcripts purging
in the middle for the same gene panel
measured hopefully you can see the very
striking comparison we found that
actually Murphy's consistently detects
70 fold more copies of each transcript
to really put this into context
Murphy has been demonstrated to have a
detection efficiency of around 95
percent in cultural cells so for a gene
that expressed 100 copies of transcripts
per cell Murphy's can get around 95
copies of that transcript of that
particular Gene while the array-based
platform can only detect 1.5 copies per
cell
so you may started to wonder what does
these numbers mean in real biology and
how does that relate to sort of
addressing certain biological questions
let's really started to zoom in more
into this data set and look at a one
model moderately expressed Gene opium
receptor Delta 1 oprd1 so in the middle
again in the mouse brain with Murphy's
High detection efficiency we can clearly
see the spatial organization of this
Gene in different brain regions however
if you look at the distribution pattern
from the oligo array-based technology
there are only a few Greek spots with
one or two counts and then there is no
clear spatial pattern
so imagine if you are actually studying
the drug effects on opium receptors how
much information will actually be missed
by using this oligo array-based
technology
furthermore if we look at the right
Murphy's measurements actually offers
two single cell resolution while in the
array-based platform each grid spot is
approximately the size of 10 cells with
a great spot size of 55 macrons
so by looking at the zoomed in image of
a single field of view from Murphy's
measurement you can clearly see where
the oprd1 gene expressed in individual
cells while that information is
completely missed in array-based
platform
so this single cell resolution of our
platform technology really allows us to
perform single cell analysis and Atlas
the cellular composition of complex
tissues
so again in this same measurement by
counting the number of transcripts with
each segmented cells and then clustering
the cells based on the gene expression
we can perform the same sort of analysis
that you can do with single cell
sequencing for example shown on the left
we can identify cell types and project
the different cell clusters identified
on this umap plot but since this is a
spatial measurement we know that
each location is recorded and then the
exact position of each of these cells is
also Illustrated on the images on the
right and hopefully you can really start
to see how we can use and leverage
Murphy's for creating cellular Atlas
so if you're interested in learning more
about these status this is the data set
we are releasing publicly it is the
measurement of nine four Chrono slices
of the mouse brain with this 483 Gene
panel I just described which profiles
all the clinical cell markers and cell
receptors like gpcrs and rtks and this
could be very relevant for many people
who are studying and doing a drug
development research or neurological uh
research so to get notified of when this
data set is available you can sign up on
our website
so that's the step in the Showcase
example I'm going to work is to
illustrate how we can actually
characterize cell function and state in
complex tissues uh this is actually a
study published in science back in 2018.
so here Murphy's was used to profile a
panel of 155 genes for a total of half a
million cells in the brain region called
mice mice hypothalamus
so in this study the gene expression
profile information among each cells
were used for clustering as just as I
just described so I will be brief here
and again as shown by the testing plot
here around 75 cell clusters will
identify in this brain region and you
can see different cell clusters for
excitatory and inhibitory neurons
on the right you can see the highly
differentiately expressed genes for
Unique cell clusters
on the left the correlation plot
Murphy's agrees very well with single
cell rna-seq actually as you can see
from this correlation plot here all the
major cell types found by single cell
rna-6 were recapitulated by Murphy's
measurements now and actually in some
instances shown by the correlation plot
on the right Murphy's was even able to
resolve different cell clusters that
were not distinguish a baba by single to
rna-seq
for example there are two clusters on
this correlation ports that are grouped
as a single cluster however Murphy's was
able to segregate that into two
different clusters
and this was really made possible by two
key features of our technology first is
the highest sales throughput by
providing more samples most cells rare
cell types will be more easily captured
and secondly this is really enabled by
the high detection efficiency which
allows node expressed but functionally
important genes to be profiled
it really further further illustrate the
high detection efficiency of Murphy's in
this study the author is actually
compared the RNA copy numbers detected
by Murphy's versus single cell rna-6
technology used in chromium so as shown
by this bar chart here Murphy's
consistently detects seven times more
transcripts than single cell rna-6 and
this really a node it also has to
profile many knowledge breast genes that
can specify cell type including
neuropeptides
and finally again as the self position
is recorded in this measurement Murphy
should further be used to catalog and
reveal the install organization in
teachers shown here on this slide now is
the cross-section images of the mouse
hypothermals with each circle now
indicating the position of all the major
cell classes from the anterior to
posterior of different region I hope you
can appreciate the fact that the
distribution of different cell types are
very heterogeneous
furthermore since Murphy's could be
readily used to profile different cell
types in state by measuring the gene
expression of an early immediate Gene
called c-force in this study Murphy's
was able to identify which neural types
are specifically activated during the
individual behaviors such as made in
parenting and aggression as you can see
aggression behaviors as you can see in
the bar chart on the top that there are
certain neuronal clusters that are
expressed in C plus much higher than the
others upon initiating those social
behaviors and of course since this is a
spatial measurement you can actually map
out where these cell types are in the
brain as shown by the images at the
bottom you will see where those cells
are responding to different social
behaviors
in a short summary I hope this example
really uh demonstrate the power of
Murphy's for cell accessing and this
application actually have profound
implications for biomarker development
mechanism of action studies to name just
a few here and it will really provide a
lot of valuable insights in
understanding complex tissue types and
cells of interactions as well
so the third showcase example that I am
going to work to illustrate how to use
Murphy's to map a more clinically
relevant example
the tumor microenvironment and the
example that I'm showing here is human
colon cancer
here we used murphage to profile 417
genes in colon cancer and what you're
seeing on this slide on the left is the
spatial distribution of 10 RNA subsets
out of these 417 Gene panel measurement
with just a few genes I hope you can
already see the rich special information
for different genes within this
particular tumor slice for example in
the zoomed in images here we see a group
of stocks now positive tumor cells
towards the top and this group of
succinite prison cells in circles stp1
expressing uh
stroma cells and at the bottom you're
seeing that adjacent to these tumor
cells there are large population of B
cells marked by the IG ha1 Gene and on
the right since we do have single cell
resolution you can keep zooming in and
try to analyze and interrogate the gene
expression within individual cells as
well
these are some of the things that we
started to see with just a few genes but
since this measurement contains 417 Gene
with single cell resolution across the
entire tissue so we can again perform
cell clustering analysis as I just
described a moment ago and identify
different cell types within the tissue
for example here this is showing all the
major immune cells including B cells T
cells NK cell centritic cells
and again the spatial distribution of
these different immune cells are
Illustrated on this slide for example
your cncd8t cells CD4 T cells no in
reach at the bottom of the this tumor
slides and then a subside a subset of
CD4 cells th 17 CD4 cells are more
enriched at the top
so the final example that I wanted to
share with you uh shows how you can use
Murphy's to directly analyze the
intracellular distribution of rnas as
some of you may know that the inter this
interested in the organization of
transcription analyze many fundamental
biological processes such as cell
migration synapse formation or even
tumor metastasis a better understanding
of this organization will definitely
help illuminate how these cells
functions
so in this recent uh post study on
bioarchive Murphy was used to profile
4200 genes in individual neurons and by
using immunostaining to trace new rights
Murphys enables the direct visualization
of different RNA species in different
neuronal compartments such as absence
dendrites and Soma and this really
annotes the identification of rnas
enriched in different neuronal
compartments for example in the plot
showing on the left what you are seeing
are the rnas enriched in the dendrites
furthermore by characterizing the
spatial distribution of different rnas
we used in the neural compartments the
authors were even able to find distinct
group of genes that shows a special
clustering effect as highlighted by the
heat Port here for example we have two
clusters cluster one and two genes sent
to colloquial synapses and very
interestingly these two groups of genes
seems to be dependent on protein
synthesis differentiate
depends on protein synthesis effect and
to some extent it is also differentiated
depending on the synaptic of synaptic
activity as well
for example if you look at the bar chart
on the bottom right you're seeing that
when we inhibit the protein synthesis
with pyromycin you can see a fraction
plus one and two genes no longer
collocalize with the synapses
in addition to all the Showcase examples
that I just Illustrated Murphy's has
been used to label genomic nose IE
individual cells and perform genoscale
chromogenetration or you can even use
this to perform image-based genetic
screens such as crispr screens however
for the sake of time today I'm not going
to go through this example in detail if
you're interested in learning more I
really strongly recommend you to look
for the papers that are started below
so I hope these few examples have given
you a good impression of what Murphys is
capable of and within Wilson we keep
pushing the limit of the technology by
expanding its application areas so far
we have proven Murphy's in more than 20
human and Mouse tissue types and a few
representative tissue types are shown on
this side in addition we aim to make
Murphy's compatible with any sample type
and tissue type as possible and we have
validate Murphy's in cultured cells
suspended cells fresh frozen fixed
Frozen and even F of T tissue blocks we
really hope that this versatile tool
could be really added into the toolbox
of any researcher and really help
accelerate their research
so the this side shows the overall
workflow of the temple prep and it's a
very straightforward process briefly you
can place multiple pieces of tissue or
cells onto our cover step and then the
sample undergoes several steps of
treatment including film mobilization
hybridization gel embedding and clearing
people putting on to our instruments for
automatic Imaging and this product is
actually very similar to a standard ish
protocol you will see and with Hands-On
time of around one to two hours in total
and in we envision that any researcher
can actually adopt it very easily
so in a short summary I hope that this
presentation gives you a good overview
of what we are doing here at wisdom and
what our Imaging platform looks like and
how you can use this to gather
biological insights we are truly excited
about the potential of our technology
and I would love to hear how we could
potentially help with your research as
well so on this side what you see is our
leadership team and we're always love to
hear feedback from your site
and with that I wanted to thank you
again for setting up the meeting and for
joining the meeting and if you have any
questions please let me know or send
inquiries to the email address shown on
this slide again thank you very much for
listening
foreign